hey everybody welcome to the podcast my
guest today is dr alan goldhamer
dr goldhamer is the founder of true
north health center in santa rosa
california
he is the co-author of this book the
pleasure trap
and he's a pioneer in the plant-based
nutrition space
this conversation is about many things
but there is a particular focus on
fasting today and
it is fascinating i think you're going
to enjoy it
if you enjoy my content in general
please take a moment to hit that
subscribe button
and without further ado please enjoy my
conversation with dr alan goldhamer
right let's do it nice to see you thank
you for coming out here to do this
it's my pleasure it's been a long time
in the coming um we're going to talk
about
fasting we're going to talk about a
whole food plant-based diet particularly
your specific bent on it the sos
version of a whole food plant-based diet
but before we do that
i think what would be really interesting
and something about your
work specifically that i find
fascinating and that i appreciate
is that it's very much rooted in as much
in
psychology as it is in nutrition science
and and physiology
and beneath all of that
again which i appreciate is the fact
that
um there are some uncomfortable truths
about
about our relationship to food that
is premised in this vernacular around
addiction and as somebody who
is a long time in recovery this is the
lens that i kind of
approach all of these things and it's
something that i think is under
addressed in this conversation about
not just a healthy diet but how we
transition to a healthy diet because
people
um you know we're emotional beings
and it's less about the information
than it is about trying to help people
figure out how to
traverse that tricky you know
sort of tight rope between old habits
and new habits and by by kind of
couching all of this
in those uncomfortable truths about our
addictive relationship with food i think
is
is really powerful well the reality is
you know humans evolved in
on a very different environment than
when we the one we live in today
we lived in an environment of scarcity
so most humans actually didn't live to
reproduce
they didn't pass on their genes they
died from predation they died from
starvation
a few survived our ancestors our
ancestors were the winners
they got enough to eat they didn't get
eaten they lived long enough to
reproduce
and our bodies and our minds were
perfectly designed for that environment
of scarcity
so now human beings being the innovative
creatures we are we change everything we
change the environment we live in
dramatically
and now we don't live in that
environment of scarcity at least most of
us don't
we live in an environment of abundance
and
although we're perfectly designed for
that environment of scarcity
this environment of abundance can trip
us up and it does
and it's responsible for the systematic
overeating that people do
that leads to the obesity that leads to
the metabolic syndrome that leads to the
vulnerability to infectious disease and
the chronic degenerative diseases the
cardiovascular disease
and many of the cancers and so that
that reality is why it's so difficult
for people to adjust to the idea that
they just can't eat as much of whatever
they want
and get away with it yeah it's almost as
if
you know if you're if you're a heroin
addict or an alcoholic everywhere you go
everybody is a heroin addict or an
alcoholic there is no
safe space right we've normalized our
behavior
and our respective relationships with
food to such an extent
that the radical notion is to step
outside
of that and do something different
two-thirds of people
in industrialized societies are
overweight or obese if you're not fat
you're abnormal
right and if you go to a physician and
you
say you're significantly overweight and
you've lost a bunch of weight
the physician doesn't immediately think
oh you must have adopted a whole plant
food diet and become an exercise program
their differential diagnosis is uh oh
this could be colon cancer
eating disorder or drug addiction
pathologize a healthy choice well the
only experience they have of people
losing weight and keeping it off is when
they've got cancer
they've developed an eating disorder or
they're a drug addict
and so it's not even in their
expectation
that people are going to actually get
well you go to a physician with most of
the diseases of dietary excess the high
blood pressure the diabetes
and they're going to tell you look
you're going to be on drugs
the rest of your life if you do what i
tell you i promise you
you'll never get well you'll be sick
forever
because it's not in their expectation
that people are going to actually
recover their health
yeah because they're not addressing the
actual reasons why they're developing
the problem to begin with they're not
addressing the causes of the problem
i think in tandem with that there's also
this pessimism
from the typical general practitioner
that
any advice or or kind of advised
protocols about healthy
lifestyle change fall on deaf ears it's
like yeah i could tell this person they
should
go to the gym or they should eat better
and and you know maybe i'm gonna maybe
i'll say that but
there isn't a real expectation that
that's gonna
move the needle or that that person is
going to be able to adhere to any kind
of
prescribed lifestyle change and and
that's because we're dealing with people
that are addicts
yes and so talk about that expound upon
expand expound upon that idea because i
think it's really important
you don't just say to an alcoholic oh
you know how your life
sucks yeah it's because you're a drunk
uh stop drinking
yeah and the alcoholic would say i've
been told that oh
it's the alcohol i had no idea
thank you so much i won't drink again
right it doesn't quite work that way
we don't currently lie to alcoholics the
same way we do
lie to people for example that are
overweight we tell alcoholics look
you have a particular vulnerability you
can't drink
you need to come up with a strategy each
and every day that allows you to not
drink
and if you can figure out how to do that
you win but if you don't
you're going to be in trouble so the
same thing is actually
true in many degrees to people that are
overweight but what we tell the
overweight person is oh
just put your food on a smaller plate
here cut your food with a knife
and and put your fork down between each
bite and you won't be overweight anymore
you just need to learn to eat moderately
and just eat a little bit less it's it's
the analog in addiction is
you know quit the quit the whiskey and
just drink beer
or put your beer in a smaller or only
binge on the weekends and maybe don't
get behind the wheel of a car
and it's not real we know with alcohol
the answer is don't drink that and the
truth is
for people that are suffering with
obesity for people who are suffering
with these diseases of dietary excess
it would be better to avoid the
chemicals that are fooling your brain
into allowing you to systematically over
consume than it would be to pretend that
you can just have a little bit
if you could have just had a little bit
you would have just had a little bit and
you would have had the thing under
control
you can't you don't if you're an
alcoholic you're not the person that can
have an occasional drink
okay and if you're the person that's
suffering with these diseases you may
find it's easier to just adopt a
strategy
that eliminates these chemicals that
fool the brain we talk about this
pleasure trap
the artificial stimulation of dopamine
in the brain that results from chemicals
that we put in our food
that fool our brain the chemicals we put
in our food
are things like salt oil and sugar these
are highly fractionated food
byproducts not food and they stimulate
the dopamine cascade in the brain
they make food taste better they make
food more
interesting to us and as a consequence
we will systematically overeat now
just like some people can occasionally
have a drink and not become a drunk
some people can have bits of this
without it becoming a
health compromising uh problem but if
you're the overweight person if you're
the person with the heart disease the
cancer the diabetes
it's not you you're the person that
would be better off saying let me
avoid those chemicals i'll stop fooling
my brain
i'll eliminate the systematic overeating
i'll reverse the disease and pathology
and i'll adapt a strategy that doesn't
include
continually beating myself up with these
things that i'm not capable of
regulating
people have an easy time understanding
that alcohol is a powerful drug
that heroin is something that is going
to kill you
the addictive nature of these substances
is
is is well understood but when it comes
to food
that's a leap of faith for a lot of
people it's it's a bridge too far to say
i understand alcoholism and drug
addiction but when you start talking
about
food as addictive you're starting to
lose me
yeah well the reality is that the the
neural cascade that's associated with
addiction of any kind is very similar
now i'm not arguing that alcohol or
cocaine or heroin might be even more
potent than say the sugar
or the oil or the salt or the
combination but the net
effect of salt oil and sugar in the diet
is actually obvious and devastating
around us it's why you see
obesity in the disease of dietary excess
that's what's making people fat
it is the hidden force that undermines
health and happiness it is a
pleasure trap and it because people
don't recognize it it's very difficult
for them to take action
uh to eliminate it at least with alcohol
most people know
oh if you're an alcoholic you probably
shouldn't drink if you go to a party
and they say oh you have some alcohol
and you say well i i can't because
you know i have an alcohol problem most
people at least will be
tolerant of you because okay you got an
issue you don't have to but if
if you go in and you say oh no i don't
want to eat you're going to really upset
people oh what's wrong with this mike
you can have this that's great a little
bit won't hurt
yeah so it's complicated it's
complicated
in terms of the internal psychology in
trying to reframe our relationship with
food but there's also
all of these social constructs that
create even additional complexity that
make it very difficult to
modify behavior there's no question in
fact the the social roadblocks to health
are probably some of the limiting
factors
i think that's probably true in all
addiction though you know one of the
challenges for people
with alcohol is oftentimes the social
consequences yes
of not participating and this is
definitely true with food we've built so
much of our social interaction around
food
that even even if you're looking to just
modify
the type of foods you eat it can be very
upsetting for people and they can get
really defensive about it
right so let's talk a little bit more
about the pleasure trap specifically
what that is you co-authored this book
seminal work with with doug lyle i've
seen his ted talk i've seen him give his
presentation many times on this subject
and that really you know elucidates this
dysfunctional relationship with food and
and why it is from an evolutionary and
psychological perspective well you know
there's this
idea of dopamine is a neurochemical
associated with pleasure
and there's two behaviors critical for
human beings survival
and that is food and sex you have to get
enough to eat in order to be able to
sustain yourself
and you have to engage in enough sexual
behavior so that you can pass on your
genes and the whole process can start
over again
so it's not surprising that food insects
are heavily reinforced
and the way the body the brain
reinforces the body's behavior is by
rewarding us with dopamine which is the
neurochemical associated with pleasure
so the more dopamine the more pleasure
the more dopamine the better the food
tastes
and so you react to food in response to
largely caloric density the higher the
caloric density the more
valuable it is in this environment of
scarcity in which we evolved
and so the higher caloric density foods
are tend to be more reinforced more
dopamine
better tasting so what we've done as
humans we're innovative creatures we
said oh if a little good
a lot's better let's figure out a way to
make the food taste even more special
by increasing its caloric density and we
do that by adding things like oil and
sugar to the food
and as a consequence we like it better
and if that's what you get used to
eating
that's all you like and eventually
people get to the point they really
don't
like the taste of simple whole natural
foods anymore because this
hyper drug like stimulating effect of
the more concentrated foods is more
appealing
so we literally become addicted for
example if you want to
neuro adapt to a lower salt or lower fat
diet it actually takes time
in order for the body to go through that
adaptation we can speed it up with
fasting but the bottom line is there is
a period of adaptation
where food doesn't taste good if you eat
whole foods and you're used to eating
highly processed foods
it's not that appealing now over time
you adapt
and then the body gets to the point
where you like the simpler foods again
yeah
people have a hard time believing that
you adapt there's this
baked in assumption that you're you're
you're
you're just gonna you're looking you're
staring down the pipeline of a lifetime
of drab
foods that are unappealing and you're
just gonna have to tolerate it
and we know there's a literature on this
though with for example sodium
uh people use on high sodium diet it
takes about a month on a low sodium diet
for the average person to neutral adapt
to a lower salt diet
you know with fat it takes almost three
months wow
it takes three months on a lower fat
diet before that satiety mechanism
that's used to being kicked in by
the higher caloric density fat begins to
adapt and you will feel
satisfied on a lower uh
density foods so the the fruits the
vegetables or grains of goons
you will now feel satisfied whereas
initially you don't because you're used
to being satiated with these high fat
uh this high fat intake and that that
can take months and
so it's a problem if you say to a person
well look you're going to eat this new
diet
you're going to feel like crap and
you're not going to like it and but
it'll only be a few months
right adherence may be lagging whereas
if you can make that process happen more
quickly
the ability to get people to make
dietary changes speeds up and that's
what we found with fasting and sometimes
that's a way of
getting people to the point where good
food tastes good more quickly yeah
there does seem to be something about
preparing people for
that stage of acclimation and there also
seems to be something
magical about the 90-day window in and
you know with drugs and alcohol that's
sort of the typical window that people
say it takes
you know it takes about that much time
to kind of wean yourself off these
cravings and
reset your system a lot of people just
wanna
they wanna they're not willing to
weather
that period of discomfort
and perhaps there's a lack of belief
that they'll reset
and be able to reframe so that you know
what they once create like
to get over the craving you have to
deprive yourself
and then you reboot and then those
things that have held you hostage for so
long
suddenly hold less and less power over
time and the fact that it can happen
more quickly
with fasting is really an interesting
thing for example smokers
you know it's not easy to quit smoking
once you're addicted to nicotine
but most smokers by somewhere between
day two and day four of fasting no
longer report with right
from cigarettes now some people say yeah
they're so miserable fasting they don't
even think about them you know
cigarettes but the reality is that that
whole adaptive process just is sped up
dramatically
now that doesn't mean you don't have
psychological and social challenges
afterwards that you still have to
address in order to sustain
good behavior patterns but just getting
rid of that first
phase of a physical withdrawal and just
feeling so crappy and feeling like you
know
you're wondering why you're putting the
effort out getting that behind you
quickly really does
enhance a person's ability to make the
transition yeah to be drug-free
i i understand the you know when you
were talking about caloric density
fat and sugar these are things that are
evolutionarily
you know we're wired to seek out and to
maximize
the salt thing though that's different
like why is it
why is it that salt is such a trigger
for people yeah this one is probably the
most controversial
recommendation that we make people have
come around as you said with oil they
realize a highly fractionated
food product like oil high caloric
density little satiety feedback you know
they can understand that sugar
pretty well accepted that refined
carbohydrates they cause your
blood uh insulin levels to rise and then
it drives your sugars
lower and it follows the brain and now
you got cravings and that's what a lot
of the binging and craving and stuff
comes around is because of physiological
alterations of refined carbohydrates
but salt also is a really important part
of this and let's talk about a few
reasons why that might be number one
um salt is an essential nutrient that is
sodium
central nutrient without which you die
fortunately you get
all of the sodium you need in a whole
natural food diet just like you get all
the sugar you need and all the oil you
need you don't have to add a
fractionated concentrated food to get
the amount of sodium the milligrams of
sodium that's needed to sustain optimum
health
salt also has a powerful effect on
passive overeating
and you can do an experiment yourself if
you just sit down and figure out how
much
brown rice you'd eat until you feel
satisfied you don't want any more
and on a different day everything else
being equal salt it up and see you'll
eat
significantly more before you feel
satisfied now some people say yeah it
tastes better
well what do you think tasting better
means it means it's stimulating more
dopamine in the brain
as a result of this artificial type
response and you will systematically
eat more on heavily salted foods when
you're adapted to that than you will
wow whole natural foods the other thing
is salt has a preservative effect
doesn't it when they salt
foods it's to keep bugs from being able
to affect it well
you have five pounds of bacteria living
in your intestinal tract right now
a trillion creatures a thousand strains
very important to your immune system to
protect you from infectious disease and
other problems
and these thousand creatures are living
eating and pooing
inside you right now so if you have five
pounds of organisms pooing inside you
you might be concerned about
what they're pooling in you because they
might be pooing some nasty toxic waste
chemicals like tma which becomes tmao
and irritates the vessels and creates a
problem if you're eating animal foods
if that's what you're feeding your
bacteria you're feeding your bacteria
soluble fibers
you're getting fertilizer you're getting
vitamin k you're getting a lot of other
good stuff so if you want
your bacteria pooling fertilizer in tea
you want to make sure you're feeding
them
a healthy diet if if salt is a powerful
preservative let's just
imagine what happens when we put a high
sodium diet into this bacterial rich
environment
it can alter the gut microbiome and so
sugar can affect it oil can affect in
silicon salt so it's been our experience
that salt in the diet is an important
part of obesity
for many people that it's an important
part for causing fluid retention which
increases blood volume which is
associated with not just high blood
pressure
but also the joint pain the congestion a
lot of the aches and pains that people
have oftentimes is because of this
fluid that the body retains to protect
itself from the consequences of salt
so it has many downstream effects even
though it doesn't have any
calories per se it can still be an
important part
of the dietary excess profile and
by eliminating the sodium from the diet
you also eliminate a lot of the highly
fractionated foods that you just can't
eat without salt
even products like bread and cookies and
crackers and a lot of this stuff without
the salt
really doesn't taste that good because
they've refined out most of the natural
flavors of the food and what they do is
they take these
federally subsidized grains like wheat
and soy and then they
and corn and they add oil salt and sugar
to it process it into various looking
foods
and call that the diet go into a grocery
store and walk around
and you'll see a lot of those foods are
really nothing more than one grain or
the other
with various concentrations of sugar oil
and salt right which
which basically allows you to make
anything taste good
and you strip away those things and
there's
something completely unpalatable right
and nutrition
nutritionally deficient underneath it
and so what we're encouraging people to
do
is a really radical departure from what
they're currently doing but that's to
adopt a whole plant food diet
that's free of this added chemicals free
of the salt oil and sugar
and what you're left with is things like
fruits and vegetables raw cooked
minimally processed grains beans nuts
and seeds but you don't have the meat
fish val eggs dairy products oil salt
sugar
and highly processed fractionated foods
that make up the majority of the
people's diet in industrialized society
and it's that diet that makes them fat
and sick and develop the disease of
dietary excess
and that what makes you vulnerable to
con infectious disease you know when you
look at what are the vulnerabilities
about why do some people get an
influenza or a covid or
an infectious disease and you know they
recover they survive
they have minimal consequences other
people it's devastating or deadly
well if you look at the risk factors
associated with what makes people
vulnerable to these diseases as well as
the disease the chronic diseases the
heart disease the cancer the stroke
it's the same metabolic syndrome in all
of its associations
it's the same obesity and diabetes and
high blood pressure and all the
consequences of dietary excess
these are reversible and preventable
conditions
people don't have to have these
conditions and even if they have them
they can largely reverse them by taking
responsibility
to control what they put in their mouth
so this is the
the underlying premise uh that that
drives
uh true north which you founded what
like 30
years ago at this point 35 in 1984
wow was when my wife dr moran and i
started true north health i can't
imagine what it must have been like to
basically open the doors to this
medically supervised
water fasting clinic back in that time i
mean now
it's all the rage we have walter longo
and all kinds of scientists studying the
phenomenon of fasting deeply it's part
of the public awareness
everybody's it's very cool to be out
there you know sort of experimenting
with intermittent fasting
this was not the case back then like i i
i mean
potentially criminal right well at one
point the california board of medical
quality assurance had
rendered an opinion that recommending
fasting to a patient
constituted such a gross violation of
the standard of medical practice
that it rose to the level of criminal
negligence i was actually the first
person in my family that required the
services of a criminal defense attorney
my father was so
proud wow what happened there
um they ultimately decided that
recommending fasting was not criminal
negligence that in fact
there was even a provision at that time
in medicare to pay for fasting but as
long as it was for rapid weight loss
necessary for urgent surgery
if you got well unfortunately it wasn't
a covered benefit
um there was also uh every hospital
today in this country will
use versions of fasting for treating
conditions like acute pancreatitis we
were able to demonstrate that this
was not criminally negligent behavior
but was actually a rather innovative
look at
trying to help sick people get well
we've gone from being criminal quacks to
cutting-edge researchers as you said
there's been some wonderful people like
walter longo
and matson and and fontana and others
that have published in major
impact journals uh this idea that
fasting or
some modification of an intermittent
fasting or modified fasting
could be a helpful tool in fact it was
interesting lanco did some research
that i think really was pivotal he
looked at
cancer treatment and he took you know 30
rats
with cancer and gave them enough
chemotherapy to resolve all the cancer
cells you have to kind of kill all the
cancer cells so they grow back
the problem is all the rats died so that
wasn't a really good outcome but he took
the same rats with the same cancer
and the same chemotherapy but he used
fasting before during and after
the treatment and not only did all 30
rats survive
but dramatically enhance cancer-free
survival and so what he found was that
there was these
things like differential stress
sensitization and differential stress
resistance that cancer cells were more
vulnerable
to the effects of chemotherapy in the
fasting states probably because of their
higher metabolic rate
they don't adapt to the environment
without glucose as well there's lots of
differences in cancer cells to healthy
cells and in the fasting states the
cancer cells were put at a selective
disadvantage
and not only that healthy cells appeared
to be protected during the fasting
from the effects of chemotherapy and at
that point people went
particularly pharmaceutically-oriented
people went oh
so fast it could make the drugs work
better oh well maybe it's not quackery
after all and so there was a lot better
tolerance and acceptance of this idea
that perhaps
fasting may have a role in enhancing
conventional treatment it was
interesting to note too that many of the
biomarkers that predict cancer and
disease
turn off whether you use chemotherapy or
not so the active fasting itself puts
the body in a selective environment that
may be more conducive to healing
and so this type of research of course
now is taking off and there's been a lot
more
uh interest and including by the work
that we're doing at the true north
health center
yeah you have this uh this study and
this experience working with a patient
who had stage three follicular
lymphoma right where you had like this
tremendous result
um yeah we had a young woman with uh
stage three follicular
lymphoma that had been uh well
documented
excisional biopsy the whole bit and had
progressed over a period of
a couple years and uh
she had asked her family physician along
the way was there anything she could do
conservatively in terms of diet and
lifestyle
he had assured that diet had nothing to
do with follicular lymphoma that she
could eat whatever she wanted eating
and when she inquired about fasting he
informed her that fasting was criminal
quackery
nonetheless she decided that she didn't
want to undergo
conventional chemotherapy because with
this particular condition
it's not really effective it doesn't
affect all cause mortality there's a lot
of side effects and so often it's not
unusual for them to defer
treatment until the condition is quite
progressed in this case
it progressed enough that he referred to
the medical school talked to an
oncologist an oncologist
also reinforced the idea that diet was
irrelevant to this condition
uh that fasting was unproven uh and
even with that advice she decided to
come to the true north health center
underwent
21 days of water only fasting during
which time her tumors that were
previously externally palpitated
palpable disappeared
so we fasted for three weeks fed her for
10 days
sent her back to the oncologist and
he examined her couldn't find any
evidence of the lesions
um expressed some surprise
uh she explained he said you know what
did you do and she said well
i went to the criminal quacks and i did
the fasting and the tumors went away
and he said well that's very impressive
suggested he'd give me a call and talk
to me about it
um she asked to have the follow-up ct
scan that we requested
and we had warned her that they might be
a little reluctant since she didn't have
any
obvious evidence of symptoms and he said
well she didn't really need a
ct scan but she said well she'd really
like to objectify
the changes that had occurred he got a
little nervous but ultimately he did
admit
agree to uh order the studies and
um he mentioned that because she was
still a little bit neutropenic maybe
some gentle chemotherapy might still be
a consideration nonetheless she refused
after a couple months for white counts
had normalized by a year she's doing
great
senator back got a whole uh you know
follow-up
evaluations and at that point we decided
that
it was time to try to write up the
report so we wrote up this
case report we submitted it to a british
medical journal
and after some back and forth they
eventually did publish the paper
they had asked us if we could get the
oncologist to sign on and so we wrote
him a letter and
it you know thanked him so much for all
the confidence he had shown in referring
the patient to us for
fasting and uh which he didn't okay well
you know in spirit and uh so uh but
unfortunately he hasn't gotten around to
responding to us yet so we didn't
how long how long ago was this uh well
what happens we published that paper
and then they asked us to do a follow-up
because they said you know about 10
percent of
lymphoma patients will go through
periods of permissive state but
sustaining it would be impressive so we
followed this patient for three years
and she continued she had lost a
substantial weight she had maintained
that weight loss for three years i think
in part because i explained to her that
you know she had to stick to the diet
or it could be fatal because i'd track
her down and kill her
and i police think she'd believe me
because she stuck to the diet
and at three years we got a whole body
ct follow up with the oncologist and
she's completely cancer free
at that point um we submitted
back to uh the british medical journal
which had invited us to
do the follow up they actually refused
the the article the first time we
we appealed and resubmitted and then
they did decide to publish the follow-up
one of the reviewers felt like well
maybe she just got lucky so
but anyway so she resolved her problem
she maintained it for three years we now
have a four year and now we're working
on a five-year fall she continues to do
well
now since then and since the publication
of that article
we've managed to treat a number of
patients with various stages including
stage four lymphoma
and so far the results look very
promising we have some follow-up data
now
we're getting in the we're in the
process of submitting another
case report with long-term follow-up on
a stage four flickr lymphoma
and ultimately we're hoping to publish
enough case reports that we can
um do a clinical trial that's amazing
justify a clinical trial because i think
we're going to do very well with this
condition in highly motivated
self-selected patients that are willing
to do dangerous and radical things like
eat well
and exercise and go to bed on time the
results seem to be promising
what led you back in the 80s to
[Music]
to basically open this clinic that's
premised upon fasting like what
what was it about your education or your
experience that
you know that that you know you found
this protocol
and what led you to believe in it in its
efficacy
well yeah it was uh it was deep
frustration
um being constantly beaten by dr lyle in
basketball
i grew up with dr lawson's fourth grade
and we played basketball and and he
would beat me and i i've known him your
whole life oh my god
and you know it was really frustrating
because he's really good so and he's
just naturally
got tremendous talent so i just thought
well i've got to be able to beat him
somehow
and so i started reading some books i
came across a book by herbert shelton it
made sense
the idea that you know health was a
result of healthful living
and that diet played a role so i thought
well i'll get an edge
and i adopted this diet vigorously and
lifestyle vigorously
thinking this was going to allow me to
be of course it failed miserably because
he adopted the same kind of eating
pattern he still beats me to this day
here we are 61 years old playing
basketball i still can't manage to beat
you your whole life is basically a
result of you trying to try to beat
doctor
okay yeah and it's and it's frustrating
i picked the wrong guy i didn't even
realize that you know the person i'm
trying to be just you know
this bookish stanford psychologist how
hard could it be
you know i thought finally i was getting
desperate i thought well i you know he's
too quick he's got
i can't but maybe i can beat him in a
free throw shooting contest because i
thought you know
free throws is just practice right so
for six months i go out i'm shooting 500
free throws a day really working on my
form
and i just casually one day say hey doug
why don't we do a free throw shooting
contest uh-huh he says
okay you know he hasn't even played for
a week well he he strikes me as a
as a like a world-class sandbagger like
the guy's always going to tell you that
he's no good right he's always down
playing right that's his whole strategy
for all of this
i go out and hit 48 out of 50 and i'm
thinking i got him
he hits 19 misses one and then hits 80
in a row
80 free throws in a row in a row 99 of
course i'm telling him well what a joke
if you can hit 99 why don't you just hit
100.
i mean yeah so the point is it total
failure
got involved trying to be a better
basketball player but what i would say
is that we're both
still playing and so you know
how good you can become in a sport may
largely be dependent on genetics and
luck
how long you're going to live in life
may be largely dependent on genetics and
love but how well you're going to live
in the time you have left may be
dependent on what you put in your mouth
and the diet and lifestyle choices that
you make and so what we're trying to
explain to patients is you're not going
to live forever you're going to die
there's been a hundred over 100 billion
humans modern humans born on the planet
there's 7.3 or 4 billion alive today but
there's only been five well-documented
people that'll live past 117.
so the thing is you're not going to live
forever but you don't have to spend the
average 9.6 years of ability or 17 years
in poor health that the average american
is spending
you know giving up compromise in the
last decades of life that could be your
richest decades of life
because of chronic degenerative diseases
because we haven't taken control of our
diet sleep and exercise patterns
and that's what we're trying to point is
you may not be able to live forever but
you can reduce dramatically
the years of debility that you have your
vulnerability to infectious disease
your likelihood of developing heart
attack stroke and other debilitating
conditions
that's where the big payoff is not
living forever
but living well until you die having a
good life and then having a good death
all right so how does the fasting come
in though a pathway towards that
so fasting is interesting because you're
dealing with people that are oftentimes
addicted to the artificial stimulation
of dopamine in their brain whether it's
to drugs
or dietary issues fasting is a great way
of breaking that cycle
it can be a very effective way of
getting the person to the point where
good foods taste good
it's a great way of lowering the blood
pressure enough you can eliminate the
the medications along with the chronic
cough fatigue the impotence and
premature death that's associated with
them
normalizing the blood sugar levels so
your insulin levels normalize so you
don't have the cravings and the binging
and all the other stuff that sometimes
go along with it
or in autoimmune diseases oftentimes
pain
is significant inflammation is only
people can't be active they can't
dissipate their attention they aren't
able to engage
effectively and so when you get people
out of pain it's like an epiphany
experience
and now the motivation goes up it's hard
to be motivated
to make diet lifestyle changes when you
feel like crap all the time
but when you get a taste of feeling good
again it's very motivating
and now oftentimes that's enough
motivation to help people overcome
their addictions and their tendencies
the reality is i found the most
effective patients or those are most
motivated and motivations that are the
most powerful
is pain debility and fear of death yeah
the only problem is you know a lot of
these people that get out of pain and
they're not fearing death anymore and
then they might slip slide a little bit
because they think i'm better now i
don't have to work quite so hard
so you know there's there's challenges
on both sides but yeah
the reality you guys have had a
tremendous success with getting
with keeping people on the path like the
recidivism rate for you is pretty low
compared to other in fairness though we
have highly motivated self-selected
people
people are willing to get bad shape well
they're motivated
yeah it's it's one thing to talk about
intermittent fasting or
you know a fasting mimicking protocol
it's another thing all together to talk
about a 40-day water fast well that is a
very
extreme moses david elijah
jesus and our patients right you know do
fascinating it's interesting that
fasting is you know shows up
in all these various religious
traditions isn't it interesting the jews
the jeans the hindus the muslims the
buddhists the christians
all these religions that's diametrically
opposed on so many things that are
killing each other in the street over
disagreements they have one thing in
common
and that's a tradition about fasting
because fasting changes how you feel
about yourself and the world around you
you can't help it
and so true north health center is not
coming from a spiritual
orientation we're coming from a very
much of a health orientation we have
different doctors with different
backgrounds and we don't try to impose
our
beliefs on anybody because we're not the
experts in you know how you get into
heaven or any of that stuff
our focus is health from healthful
living but virtually every major
religion has a tradition
i mentioned not just about fasting but
also about the value
of a whole plant food diet you know
these um
traditions resonate throughout history
and
you know the reality is perhaps it's
because that's what works
how dare you
all right so walk me through
all right well first let me say this so
in the in the
decades that you've been doing this you
and doug have taken
and and your staff i mean i've had i've
had
you know chef aj in here explained to me
her
you know experience of being at she goes
to true north like
for vacation when she wants to get out
of town i mean she
she's got to be your most regular
customer um
but i've had i've had dr longo talking
about fasting
uh who else have i had in here i've had
you know true north comes up all the
time on the podcast
so i've heard about it anecdotally and
over the years you've taken what like 20
000 people through this
fasting procedure you know and had
tremendous success so i want to
understand
the the process that is entailed here
somebody comes to you
they're in bad shape they're overweight
they have hypertension diabetes obese
cardiovascular disease whatever you know
this is the kind of person that's
arriving in your doorstep
so the first step is that they usually
go to our website
so they go to truenuthealth.com and they
fill out the registration forms which
gets us their medical history
and we get their previous laboratory
work that comes in and they get a free
phone conversation with me so we offer
people free
you still do that right like still do
they call up and you'll give them a free
consult
i still do that so i talked to them as a
screening about whether or not
fasting might be appropriate if anything
that we do or we recommend might be
helpful for many people they may not
even need or be ready for fasting but
they may just need to talk to a doctor
that's not a complete idiot so we have a
phone coaching service where
our attendings are available they go
online through the website
we have all their medical records put
together they can schedule a formal
phone call uh consultation with one of
our attending physicians they can
discuss
get a second opinion they can do
whatever they want to do where they talk
to a doctor they can look at their
history objectively
and give them advice um if there are
appropriate candidates
for fasting then i schedule them into
the
center for a stay i give them an idea
about what we expect as a reasonable
period of time
they come to the center they go through
with one of our attending physicians a
history exam
laboratory monitoring we initiate them
into a fasting protocol if that's
appropriate
and then after fasting they go through a
refeeding process now while they're
there
fasting they're seen twice a day by our
staff doctors we make sure it's done
safely and effectively they're monitored
carefully
we have detailed educational classes
what i call brainwashing
where they're able to go through all in
detail the process about what they're
going to need to do why they're going to
need to do it
there's some social dynamics because
they're there with other people from
around the world that are getting a
chance to do this
you know our facility has about 70
patients staying at it
so they're interacting with those other
people plus the
the staff and the educators and so it's
a pretty
like immersion type of inexperience they
go through fasting they go through
re-feeding
if they have specific health problems we
have chiropractors naturopaths
body workers all that kind of stuff that
they can get the kind of attention
that they need and then when they're
going home they have very specific
recommendations that we expect them to
follow
and we try to provide follow-up support
and then because of the phone coaching
they're able to continue to access these
attending doctors
affordably without necessarily because
you know half our people are out of
state
15 are four and they're not all living
locally where they can pop in
and right see our doctors or use our
deli business or you know any of that
kind of stuff
what are what are the important vectors
or variables that determine
the appropriateness or you know for
somebody to
do one of these protocols like not
everybody is suitable for this
no the biggest one is that they have a
condition
that is appropriate for fasting so
there's many uh people
that are not good candidates for fasting
and we can talk about that
there are some things that are
particularly amenable to fasting and for
example the conditions that are caused
by dietary excess
are particularly responsive to fasting
it makes sense
obesity cardiovascular disease high
blood pressure
type 2 diabetes autoimmune diseases
certain forms of cancer
these conditions we know are made much
worse by poor dietary choices so it's
not shocking to find out
that fasting kind of the ultimate in
undoing the consequence of excess
would facilitate the recovery of those
patients and it does and we've been able
to prove that we've been publishing
papers looking at these conditions like
high blood pressure looking at diabetes
looking at autoimmune diseases
and the fact is we can in highly
motivated patients
generate safe and effective uh responses
with fasting right in fact we've
actually published a fasting safety
study the first
comprehensive look at long-term water
only fasting and what the risks are in
art
uh in response to this process so we've
been able to show it is a safe process
when it's done according protocol in
fact dr
longo who cautions people in his book
about long-term water fasting and its
safety
makes an exception and that's if people
fast at the true north health center
because he's familiar with our safety
now i evaluate other scientists
intelligence based on how much they
agree with me right i'm glad
i'm glad you know your bias is intact
here
um if somebody has
anorexia nervosa or if somebody is
uh you know on the other side of
chemotherapy where they're
maintaining their weight is an issue i
would suspect that that's probably not a
great candidate what about
somebody who's coming in and they're on
a battery of medications you would
you would have to wean them off of that
i would presume on some level before
they could undergo this
yeah you know there's um most
medications you do not water fast while
you're taking medications those have to
be weaned down
beforehand but we have physicians that
are experts at helping people
unwind the consequences of their medical
treatment and most medications
interestingly enough
the day you change the diet you have to
begin changing the medication profile
right because most medications are
treating the diet
most people are being treated that is
medicated
for their diet when you change their
diet
the need for medication dramatically
responds you have to reduce
the blood pressure medication you start
crashing these patients because they're
not going to be hypertensive
once you eliminate the reasons why
they're hypertensive
and they're not going to be needing the
same level of medication once you
normalize their dietary intake as far as
their diabetes or
getting them off their pain medication
once they don't have the pain they don't
need to be on all that oxy
because now the pain is being reduced
because the inflammation has been
reduced because of the dietary change
and then ultimately the fasting
so that's one of the reasons why fasting
does need to be done in a controlled
medically supervised setting it's not
the kind of thing that you do
long-term fasting at home at home right
you know
so you do that in a controlled setting
where there's been a proper history exam
lab and daily monitoring so we're seeing
each of these patients twice a day
and that's how we're able to ensure that
this is a safe and effective experience
so they may withdraw their medication
with careful feeding
initiate the fasting normalize the
condition and then after we're done
most of the time there's no need for
medication because their blood pres you
know they've gone from 220 over 120
capped out on five meds
to being 120 over 70 off medication
and so there's no reason for anybody to
want to put them back on drugs that
cause chronic cough fatigue impedance
and premature death
if the condition is actually normalized
now the side problem is
you have to keep on the healthy diet and
lifestyle yeah because you're not curing
anything
you're just managing it but you've
rebooted this operating system
and wiped the slate clean so you can
build a new foundation
it's very much like treating a you know
when your computer becomes corrupted and
you don't know exactly what's wrong but
you turn the thing off you turn it on
you can't explain
but now it's working right and it seems
and we're trying to figure out exactly
what those changes are that's occurring
uh in fasting the i know the
pharmaceutical injury is very interested
in what's happening because they want to
come up with what are called fasting
mimicking drugs
they want drugs that will do just what
fasting does to you but without that
nasty fasting
that's something that they can sell in a
pill yeah so a lot of the research
of interest is trying to figure out what
exactly is it that's happening in
fasting that's allowing the body to get
well so that we can try to reproduce
that without having to go through the
process right i mean that's my next
series of questions like does it have to
be
water only what is it about that
deprivation protocol that is so special
um you know uh physiologically
that is causing this cascade of positive
impacts like what would happen if you
were eating a little bit i mean i know
what
longo has this fastic fasting mimicking
um protocol where he is allowing people
to eat something like i don't know 600
calories a day
and he's able to reap some of the
benefits of what you're experiencing
without having to go on a complete water
fast but
what is happening to the body when
you're depriving it of food in such a
you know comprehensive way yeah the
intermittent fasting protocols are just
that
fasting mimicking diets or fasting
mimicking programs trying to reproduce
some of the changes that we know occur
with fasting without the risk profile or
the complications of long-term water
only fasting
and i think they can be very effective
as they've demonstrated
however long-term water-only fasting
has a much more profound impact on these
mechanisms that are associated with
fasting for example
just the most obvious is weight loss you
know when you're water fasting you're
going to lose an average of a pound a
day
now some people say well you lose weight
but then you gain it back afterwards now
interesting we've done a study we have
now uh recently acquired a
hologix dexa scanner with the new
software that allows you to do a whole
body detail composition it looks not
just a
percent body fat but how much visceral
fat there is and we have a paper that
will be coming out that looks at
the fact that yes you lose a bunch of
weight fasting and you regain some
weight after fasting but it turns out
the weak weight you regain after fasting
when you're eating a whole plant food
diet is exclusively water
fiber glycogen and protein there is no
fat in fact the fat profile continues to
drop during re-feeding
even though the scale weight obviously
goes up as you rehydrate put some fiber
back into right
as long as you adopt as long as you
continue to adopt the whole plant food
healthy
you know dietary style but the point
that the old wives tale was well you
lose fat and you just gain the fat right
back well
that might be true if you go back to
eating greasy fatty slimy dead decaying
flesh processed foods but that's not
what's happening
in these patients that we're re-feeding
appropriately
and so weight goes up but what the
weight that goes up is re-elementing
your glycogen stores and
muscle stripes which is really exciting
so preferentially
not just do you lose fat but you
preferentially lose
visceral fat that the ratio of visceral
fat to adipose tissue loss is 3.0
in other words there's a significant
preferential immobilization of this very
type of fat that we think is most
compromising to health
the fat the abdominal fat stores around
the organs so
now we have what may turn out to be an
effective strategy of specifically
mobilizing visceral fat
now we've done some preliminary work we
have we're actually enrolling patients
in the study starting in august
looking specifically at body composition
changes long term with follow-up so
you know we'll be able to speak more
definitively about it by the end of the
year
there's also a process that happens in
water fasting that you don't see as
profoundly
influenced in juice diets or modified
diets and that's natural resistance
there's a selective mobilization
elimination of excess sodium from the
body
and water fasting it happens right away
it's very powerful more powerful than
say taking hydrochlorothiazide or a
diuretic
and it's responsible for the big dump in
fluids that happens initially on fasting
that drops blood pressure so
dramatically gets rid of the congestive
heart failure symptoms that eliminate
some of the arthritic symptoms and joint
swelling
and the non-healing wounds and this by
selectively getting rid of this excess
sodium that's accumulated
that the body's having to deal with
because of the dietary choices
the traditional justification for
fasting was the idea of detoxification
this idea that there's toxins in the
body and now we know that's
true they've actually been able to
that's controversial well it's actually
not controversial in the sense that you
can take a fat biopsy of a human
and break it down and you'll find
there's hundreds of different chemicals
there at various concentrations pcb
dioxin pesticide residues mercury
and the only thing that's controversial
is that oh well it doesn't matter
well it turns out it does matter it just
matters at different thresholds to
different people
and so this this idea of rapidly
mobilizing toxins during fasting
has been so uh well accepted by some
that they say that's the reason not to
fast because the body would rapidly
mobilize these fat soluble nutrients too
quickly and your body wouldn't know what
it's doing
and it would overload your system unless
you take their proprietary products
then apparently it's okay but what our
experience has been that there is a
rapid detoxification
we know that there are some studies
looking at they've even done total body
load measurements before and after
fasting and showed that pcb levels would
drop
um clinically you're not taking any
chemicals into your body
and you're allowing the liver and the
kidneys to just do what they do
right but it's more than just what you
would calculate
through burning 2000 calories of
internal fluids there's a selective and
rapid mobilization for example
with tumors let's say you have a breast
tumor
and you lose 10 percent of your body
weight
you would assume that you'd probably
lose 10 percent of your tumor weight but
what happens in
the for example in lymphoma you lose 100
of the tumor
so the body's preferentially mobilizing
some nutrient stores
versus others and it seems to be able to
do that in inverse proportion of the
value of those
tissues to the body right so it's
getting the visceral fat which we think
isn't probably healthful fat
before it's mobilizing adipose fat and
certainly before it's getting to
critical nerve tissues and other things
that are preserved the body has an
intelligence where it's unwinding itself
and what we're suggesting is
it appears that both endogenous and
exogenous toxins are preferentially
mobilized in water only fasting
at a much more powerful rate than they
are saying when you're going on a
healthy diet
and lifestyle and that may be a way a
justification for
trying to facilitate and speed this
process
there's also the effect on enzymatic
induction think about athletes
one of the things of being a trained
athlete is you induce for example
glycogenolytic enzyme systems you get
better at mobilizing glycogen stores and
you know this whole business of carb
loading and trying to increase
uh glycogen storage so you have more to
pull on so that you don't hit the wall
so quickly when you're running that
marathon or whatever you get through
that process
though that isn't induced with
persistent exercise
the same enzymatic production for
glycogen for
what balitic enzymes for a protein for
gluconeogenesis
enzyme systems is induced during fasting
because you have to mobilize
all your glycogen stores you're entering
the chamber you're taking that battery
and draining it all the way down
and and it's suggested that not only do
you induce
improved efficiency of enzyme systems
but they persist
after fasting which is just like you get
better and better at exercising every
time you do it
you get better and better at fasting
every time you do it which is perhaps
one of the justifications for
intermittent fasting if you fast 16
hours every day
and you limit your feeding window to an
eight hour window you may be inducing
some changes in that
even that limited fast that 16 hour fast
day after day after week after month
cumulatively
that may have a very profound effect on
body physiology and that's one of the
suggestions that's being made by those
advocating
intermittent fasting or short periods of
fasting that cumulatively may be
well when you do a long term fast this
is a
huge impact and now this is some of the
stuff we're working with people like
luigi fontana from washington university
where they're looking at changes in
microbiome
changes in whole body composition
changes in these
these various exotic biomarkers and what
happens in short-term and long-term
fasting
nobody knows yet because we're really
the only people doing
and monitoring long-term water only
fasting and its physiological effects
so this is all virgin data and very
exciting but what we can see clinically
is that
when you induce changes with exercise or
you induce changes with fasting they're
often
the same changes if you look for example
exercise people that
exercise two rats in a cage genetically
identical give one rat an exercise wheel
and the other not
everything else is equal the rats with
the exercise wheel
one they'll use it and number two they
don't get alzheimer's disease and
dementia
and they said well why why does exercise
prevent how does exercise prevent
dementia
and they look at those rats and they
find out that bdnf brain derived
neurotrophic factor
is dramatically higher and rats that get
their exercise
lower and those that don't the ones that
don't much more vulnerable to
alzheimer's
well bdnf it turns out the precursor to
that is beta-hydroxybutyric acid which
is the fatty acid that your brain is
preferentially mobilizing during water
only fasting
bdnf goes up with water fasting just
like it does in
exercise glycogen mobilizing enzymes go
up and exercise just like they do in
fasting
in fact all of the biomarkers that we've
been able to look at that are improved
with exercise
improve with fasting which is weird
because you think wait a second
exercise you're up vigorously running
around inducing all these changes
fasting you're sitting around we don't
even let you exercise much you maybe can
do a little yoga
how is it that they would do the same
thing to the body but when you think
about it
exercise and fasting are both reversing
the consequences of dietary excess
when you exercise vigorously when you
fast you're undoing the consequence of
diatrixes
i'm not surprised at all that fasting
induces the same kind of bio changes
that we see with exercise
in fact for us it's saving a lot of time
because we just look at all that fast
exercise literature
and start looking for the things they've
discovered and seeing how much of it's
mimicking
mimicked with fasting um i think that
both of these processes fasting and
exercise
share a common biological benefit
and that's why we're seeing the
biomarkers changing with both
that is crazy the other thing that
happens is insulin insulin is the
hormone that drives sugar from the
bloodstream
into the cells where it's needed to burn
so if you look at type 2 diabetics you
might assume mistakenly that they don't
have enough insulin
they have plenty of insulin they have
more insulin it doesn't work
because there's insulin resistance
there's resistance to the insulin
carrying out its function
so what drug can you take that reverses
insulin resistance
there isn't any there's drugs that will
force sugar bond the cell and they have
all kinds of side effects
what can you do to reduce insulin
resistance well you could exercise
you know that helps weight loss healthy
diet
um you can fast fasting has a profound
effect on insulin resistance in fact
as much as 80 percent of our type 2
diabetics can achieve normal blood sugar
levels without medication
and if they're willing to continue to do
the diet and the exercise they can often
sustain those results now you might say
well couldn't they do that with just
diet and exercise
absolutely many diabetics that are able
to make aggressive diet lifestyle
changes over enough time are successful
at resolving and reversing their
diabetes but it's difficult for people
that aren't able to do it on their own
that's where we would use
the next level of support and
intervention which is fasting it can
also be a little tricky
unwinding the medications and all that
kind of stuff so you know doing whatever
it is whether it's feeding or fasting in
conjunction with doctors that are
able to be supportive and that have an
expectation of you getting well is
important now think about it
if you go to a doctor and you've lost
weight
does the doctor assume you've adopted a
healthy diet
no they assume you've
got an eating disorder you're a drug
addict or you're dying of cancer
you know that's the differential colon
cancer eating disorder
drug addiction because many doctors have
never had an experience of a diabetic
getting well i gave a lecture
this year in texas at a medical
conference
for physicians who specialize in
diabetes so there's 250 people there
what are they serving them pulled pork
sandwiches chocolate cake
you know most of them are overweight or
obese i do my presentation
i explain our results afterwards one of
the ducks comes up he's about maybe 70
80 pounds overweight
he says you know i've been in practice
25 years treating diabetics
i've never seen one get well he's never
had the experience of a single
patient recovering stabilizing his blood
sugar taking off medication
it's not part of the paradigm
how likely is he going to give
meaningful diet and lifestyle advice to
a patient when he
doesn't do it himself doesn't believe
doesn't even know
that it would work or even if you
thought it would work knows the
patient's not going to do it because
people don't make diet lifestyle changes
he's seen the literature
93 recidivism rate that that you know
you
is to ask people to make diet lifestyle
changes very difficult
so when you get up and you give a
presentation like that to
that type of audience what is the
receptivity to what you're saying
well in the past it was aggressively
negative
now it's actually becoming where at
least a percentage of the audience is
actually interested the way that we made
that contact was
one of the doctors that that runs the
residency training program came in
had his own experience wanted it for his
students and now
those second and third year residents
can rotate as part of their training
at the true north health center so they
can get the experience of actually doing
something that some of them have
never done before which is see these
patients get well
because under a conventional treatment
you don't get to do that and it turns
out there's some doctors that rings
their bell
they like the idea of patients getting
well and so they're willing to put the
extra time and energy and effort in
but if you're in a traditional system if
you're an hmo system and you're a
physician and you have to see 26 patient
contacts a day
do you think you have time to review
their history do an exam
write the prescriptions and then sit and
ch chat about them why they've got to
give up everything that they eat
for that no it's not set up for that
it's not set up for the accountability
that's required to
get somebody to maintain any kind of
lifestyle change protocol
anyway and i'm not sure many of them
even realize that it's
actually worth their time because
they've never actually seen it happen
before
so you know and of course the criticism
is well yeah but you're working with
special patients well that's true
we're working with the people that are
highly motivated self-selected willing
to make diet lifestyle changes
it is a self i'm not saying you can take
our advice give it to everybody and
everybody's just going to go
oh great whole plant food diet just what
i wanted that's not the reality
but for people that are willing and
interested they should at least have the
right
somebody should listen well you could go
on this diet and lifestyle
you know but it's a lot of work or you
can just take these pills and you'll be
sick forever
what do you want to do you know but they
don't even know that it's not i can
guarantee this physician i was talking
to never tells his patients well if you
did
radical and diet lifestyle changes you
could get i'll give you an example my
brother my brother's six years older so
we're raised together he's
slowly gaining weight his wife
adopts our diet comes in and fast
overcomes her own health issues
he's on a vegan program 15 years later
my brother's still eating chicken and
doing stuff and getting fatter and he's
got
he can't play volleyball anymore his
legs all swollen up
i you know i'm poking him but he he
won't do anything finally he calls me
from the hospital
he says alan i'm in the hospital i had a
heart attack
i said that's great he goes no no no you
don't hear
i had a heart attack i said i hurt you
best thing that could have happened so
he said oh they want to do a quadruple
bypass
and i said well talk to your surgeon ask
the surgeon says
if you do a bypass won't they plug up
again and search
yeah eventually but you know lasts
longer than stenson he says
what if i made radical diet and
lifestyle change
he said the surgeon laughed at him he
said mark
you're not gonna make diet and lifestyle
changes come on
checked himself out got on a whole plant
food sos free diet
lost the 50 pounds back to playing
volleyball past his stress test still
has his vessels
wow but my own brother it took yeah it's
willing and ability
it's just like in 12 step it's like it's
all about willingness
and pain is is the fulcrum for that
right when people are in a desperate
state or they've suffered
a you know a severe medical
you know trauma like that then they're
ready to actually
implement those kinds of changes short
of that it's very difficult and i think
that
speaks to the pessimism that most
practitioners have about the
you know the viability of advising
somebody to change their lifestyle
habits
absolutely i completely understand this
is amongst the most difficult thing you
can ask a patient to do
adopt a health promoting diet in a world
designed to make you fat sick and
miserable
not an easy task certainly not for
sissies
and in my brother's case you know he had
the advantage his wife my sister-in-law
already
doing the work of providing support to
the family with
healthy food and stuff but still
difficult
now i just saw him a few days it looks
great completely different person
do you think he's going to like oh no it
wasn't worth it you know no it's the
best thing he's ever done
fabulous so you you approach fasting
from a perspective
of of um weight management and also
disease prevention and reversal but
there's al also all this emerging
science around longevity and anti-aging
of course that's longo's you know
specific lens on this but
by dint of autophagy and all these other
you know like sort of you know
biomechanical systems that are affected
by fasting there's now this whole
world of research opening up around
prolonging life as a result of
this i actually think the people that
are going to turn out to get the most
benefit from fasting
this one in two week fast that we do
with healthy people is healthy people
healthy people that are looking to stay
healthy too for example to avoid
vulnerability of infectious disease to
avoid the problems that you know not
waiting like my brother did until he has
a heart attack but the people that are
willing to use it to prevent the
problems from beginning
and interestingly enough i've been
communicating with walter long ago
recently about doing a joint study where
we're going to use his
expertise and access
and our facility to do some look not
just at intermittent fasting
but long-term fasting and compare and
contrast and see what the very best bang
for the buck so to speak of is in terms
of
taking healthy people and helping them
stay that way we've got a study that's
planned for next year looking
specifically exotic biomarker changes
with these dietary changes with fasting
and then trying to differentiate
how much fasting how frequently what's
the right combination that's all
relatively new uh territory you know
there's other
impacts of fasting that are not as well
recognized for example
the gut you have a tunnel through your
body that starts your mouth and it goes
down your
esophagus and your stomach and your
intestinal tract and gets to the rectum
you've got a hole at one end and another
hole at the other end and digestion is
essentially shoving things in one hole
trying to push it out the other hole but
it's only the stuff that gets absorbed
the intestinal mucosa that enters the
body
and that intestinal mucosa acts like a
screen
keeping flies out if the screen becomes
inflamed things can leak through that's
essentially what gut leakage is
and the things that cause inflammation
of the gut we believe are free radicals
that come from not just smoking or
drinking alcohol
you know smoking it's obvious you see
smoker's face cross-linked collagen
tissues we know that's
cross-linkaging from the free radicals
from smoking it also affects the
animal lining of the blood vessels it's
my contention that cigarette smoking may
protect people from getting lung cancer
actually protects people well think
about it
eighty percent of smokers say that come
on eighty percent of smokers never get
lung cancer
and twenty percent of smokers get cancer
and i believe it's because smoking kills
people from heart attacks before they
live long enough to grow their tumors
because of the damage to the animal
lining of vessels
cardiovascular disease may occur
slightly quicker than the
inevitable lung cancer would have and so
if you could make smoking more dangerous
and kill everybody from heart disease
perhaps they could advertise it as
cancer safe
okay now i understand
well you know they say statistics don't
lie that liars use statistics
and the fact is you can look at these
this data and twist it around
in a way that sounds good even though
it's completely ridiculous right smoking
damages animal lining it damage it
causes lung cancer
alcohol peroxidation of alcohol leads to
cirrhosis of the liver
why do you think people that drink a lot
of alcohol get fatty liver it's a scar
tissue that comes from the
detoxifying effect of that nasty alcohol
but today they're trying to tell you
that alcohol is health food
if you don't drink you should start that
resveratrol a little bit of
powerful antioxidant from this grape
skin is some justification for drinking
alcohol
they're trying to take oh it thins the
blood like aspirin does so if you're on
a greasy fatty slimy dead decaying flesh
diet and risk of clotting stroke
that thinning effect is going to reduce
your risk of dying from a clotting
stroke which might be true
but you're going to increase your risk
from a hemorrhagic stroke you're not
going to reduce your all-cause mortality
so the only reason to drink alcohol is
if you'd rather die of a bleeding stroke
than a clotting stroke maybe that's a
justification
you're a passionate man dr goldhammer
why is it that uh why 40 days or 21 days
like what is it about that extended
period that's so important
well what we do is we want to fast as
short as possible but long enough to get
the problem resolved
and so it's not like we're setting out
to try to beat jesus in the in fasting
duration
we don't go over 40 days generally
because if you keep the fasts
under 40 days there's few metabolic
complications as you start getting into
the really long fasts
the 60 days the 80 days the longer fast
that were done in the past
it's a much more delicate balance in
terms of electrolyte balance and other
things
and so the guy that i trained with alec
burton in australia used to do fast as
long as 100 days or longer
and i asked him by the time i got there
that was 36 years ago
he was no longer doing over 40 days as a
routine just
very occasionally and i said why and he
said well because of the sleep
deprivation
i said oh i didn't know that patients
had any more trouble
sleeping on long-term fascicles oh no
not the patients
me he had sleep deprivation he was just
worried too much yeah he'd worry too
much about it so he
he decided to keep it to 40 days because
we knew from experience that that was
the period of time you could go without
getting into more of the
complications and there's no electrolyte
supplementation or
vitamin and mineral supplementation
during this period you're looking at me
like
there's crazy water only fasting is the
complete abstinence of all substances
except pure water in an environment a
particular kind of water
we use fractionally steam distilled
water just because it's pure water
patients that are fasting get really
sensitive they won't tolerate municipal
contamination and other stuff they just
want pure water it's h2o it's just what
rainwater would be if the environment
wasn't polluted and so anytime you start
supplementing like for example there
were some long-term fasts done by
medical authorities that that killed
people
and the reason why is because they
supplemented what they would do is they
would supplement potassium if potassium
got low but
if you don't allow something to be the
rate limiting nutrient and you're not
measuring obviously everything that's
possible to be measured
you can get into depletion of something
else and they did you see evidence in
the literature of myocardial fibril
breakdown or other problems that you'll
not see
if you don't let the rate limiting
nutrients be rate limiting for example
potassium is pretty sensitive
if you don't supplement potassium and
you use potassium as a rate limiting
mineral all the downstream things that
you might not necessarily
know to measure are not likely to become
an issue so we use 3.0 potassium as
an arbitrary termination if it gets
below that then we modify the protocol
now it's not necessary to do that you
could push people further but if you use
that as a protocol we've proven you can
do it safely and effectively
over 20 000 consecutive times the reason
why we've been able to do this so
consistently is we have strict protocols
that we follow
that are time tested and proven and
supplementation of electrolytes although
you might think well potassium would
just give them some potassium but that's
an example
of letting arrogance exceed your
ignorance because you don't know what
the downturn
consequences of that is and so we're
using a protocol that we've been able to
test now it may be there's a better way
to do it and that's why we do research
and that's why we look at these things
or maybe
but until that's done i exercise caution
because the fact is this is a
you're in a physiologically vulnerable
state particularly in a person that's
coming off medications and
has a health history and you want to
make sure that everybody that walks in
walks out and that's why we use the
protocol we do
i would suspect also a psychologically
delicate state
walk me through the experience of this
journey that you see with the typical
patient i mean you're demanding a lot of
them
they're going through something they've
never done before like what is the
you know what it what is that like for
that individual when they're on day
three day 10
day 30 yeah so the first a few days of
fasting are actually the most difficult
because you're adapting off the
uh alpha glucose metabolism into a fat
metabolism so the brain is changing
fuels
from burning sugar to blurring largely
beta-hydroxybutyric acid which comes
from the ketone bodies from the fat
breakdown
so there's an adjustment there you're
detoxing oftentimes a lot although we've
learned to minimize
the effect of detoxification by getting
people to eat
a fruit vegetable only diet for a few
days before we start fasting
that's made a huge difference so they're
not coming off caffeine addiction at the
same moment that they're trying to adapt
to the fast
they've already gotten that stuff out of
their system and that's actually the
most difficult stuff
getting the cigarettes the caffeine the
alcohol all the meat fish foul eggs
dairy products processed foods
all the host of chemicals that people
are putting into their body with
over-the-counter prescription
medications so we've gone through a
wean-down process
and then we start fasting and their
mouth may coat up and taste like
something crawled in there and died
and they may have some skin rashes or
elimination they may get mucus
discharged they may get
some vivid dreams they may have aches
and pains and
they may have difficulties with all
kinds of adaptive process but they go
away
and then something else comes along and
then it goes away and then it becomes
very empowering
because they realize that they're able
to get through this process that just
because they had a headache doesn't mean
they have to rush out and try to
suppress those symptoms of the pill
it goes away the body's able to heal
itself and then
once you get into four or five days of
fasting the body's pretty well
acclimated to the fasting at this point
there's no hunger
people are going to cooking
demonstrations they're coming to
lectures they're going to the dining
room to socialize with people
they're five days ten days into a fast
you think oh my god you haven't eaten
for 10 days no just enjoy being there
that's not a problem um so then um
depending on the patient sometimes they
start getting relief they're pain
maybe for the first time in years the
pain that they've been suffering with
is going away and they may find that
you know some people have these chronic
debilitating problems
start resolving things start falling off
tumors start shrinking they start
getting excited like oh maybe there's
something to this idea of the body
healing itself
and you know we're monitoring these
patients to go through the process and
then at some point you get to the point
where
there's a limiting factor maybe their
electrolytes start to drop a little bit
or their energy is not
acceptable they're not able to maintain
accurate ambulation or maybe they've
just
that's how much time they've got because
you know some people have jobs and lives
and responsibilities so we only have so
much fun here for 40 days
so my life completely craters on the
outside but for many people this is an
intense epiphanic experience because
they've got this intense education that
they're really open to
they've seen these other people
sometimes what looks to them like
miracles going on
because they're seeing people that they
have no expectation that that could get
well
getting well they're experiencing
themselves sometimes for the first time
you know a sense of empowerment because
they're able to actually reverse these
processes that they were told nothing
could be done
learn to live with it what do they
expect at their age that's just how it
is
and now they're thinking wow if they
were wrong about that maybe they're
wrong about other things too
you start you know looking at all
aspects of their life the empowerment
aspect of it has got to be huge like
even if you set aside
all of these you know physical benefits
that are a result of this
simply the fact that they did something
that seems impossible very very
difficult
and get to the other side of it has to
you know sort of um make them feel like
okay now nothing is impossible like i
just did this thing that almost nobody
does now
now what's the next challenge that i can
tackle you know the idea is that many
people think that if you fast you die
they believe if they got on a plane in
new york and they were to fly all the
way to california
they would die over colorado except they
ate the peanuts
you know that the pretzels saved their
life what do you eat when you fly and
somehow if you fasted for
10 days or 20 days sometimes the idea
that you might have to skip a meal
because there was nothing healthy to eat
doesn't seem quite so overwhelming
there's definitely empowerment and i
think that
the other thing that happens is when you
start feeling what it feels like to be
you
instead of what you'd become that's very
important i think the same thing happens
to athletes
you know when people first start
exercising at first it's not pleasant
they got aches they got pains they
they're fatigued they're not they're not
getting the success they can't do what
they want
but as they do it they get to the point
where not only do they tolerate they're
not just doing it because they want to
you know maintain the weight or get the
figure or whatever it they're doing is
they start realizing they're getting
real intrinsic benefit
from engaging in this consistent
activity and now they don't want to give
it up
and i think the same thing happens when
people really get into a healthy
lifestyle yeah they're really exhausted
they don't want to go give it up and
feel like everybody else feels because
of some greasy slimy convenient food
they're willing to pay the price of
trying to do the planning and do what it
takes to try to ensure that they can get
their needs met just like i think people
that get into a regular exercise regime
realize that now this is so beneficial
they will literally structure their
schedules around making sure that that's
an important part of their activity
and the same thing happens with sleep
when you realize how important sleep is
to health and maintenance and energy you
start prioritizing that
and you don't compromise your sleep you
don't compromise your exercise
and hopefully you don't you learn to not
compromise your time lifestyle i tell
people
here's what you need to do first get
enough sleep because it's your most
critical activity
then engage in regular exercise so you
can dissipate the tension you can
build fitness and have the time to
prepare and eat healthy food if there
happens to be any time left well fine
you go to work
[Laughter]
um let's talk about the uh
the food part of all of this so uh
well first of all does anybody freak out
in the middle of this and
flee like i can't handle it like there
has to be some people that just
psychologically can't handle it you'd be
surprised by the time people come to the
trunk health center they're pretty well
vetted
they've gone through some screening
we've evaluated their history they're
usually pretty motivated
most of the time the only way they find
out about us is some doctor or somebody
they know is referring to us to begin
with yeah
and you know it's like you're not going
to refer somebody that if you know
what's going on there
that's not going to be a good candidate
so there's a lot of filtration that goes
on
and so the exceptions that i've seen
i've had some patients that are coming
off
drugs like cocaine and other stuff that
don't last 12 hours you know because
they're just they're not really ready to
make the change
but as far as fleeing because the diet
no because the true north health center
is set up to meet people where they're
at
not everybody's ready to do vigorous
water only fast or should would it even
be appropriate so for those individuals
maybe we just do a healthy eating regime
and just eating the diet doing the
classes doing the yoga the meditation
is enough to induce significant changes
sometimes after they've been a while
they might say well you know maybe i'll
try a little intermittent fasting maybe
i'll try a little bit of a fast and see
how i do with that and that's fine so
it's not like
everybody comes in and we lock them up
and that's it in fact
you know i tell a story when we first
moved to the new facility
one day a really large police officer
showed up at the door and he said he
wanted to interview one of my patients
and i asked him what did they do and
they said well
you know i don't need to know and i said
well if you want me to tell you if
they're here or not i need to know you
know what the issue is and he said okay
we got a complaint and the complaint was
from this patient's relatives and they
said they were that the patient was
being held against their will
by religious cultists and being starved
to death to go to be with jesus
[Laughter]
and i thought i'd say like the person's
not here involuntarily and you know i
got into i said fine
i'll let you interfere but first would
you like a nice tall cup of kool-aid
uh-huh right and dr lyle says that when
a police officer puts
relishing in your role as a cult leader
he is not comfortable
and i'm not to speak to authorities
anymore but that's you know i'm thinking
it's an obvious joke because kool-aid is
full of sugar where would you serve that
at the trump health center
well i know it's funny the reality is
that today it's not as much of an issue
because now the idea of fasting doesn't
yeah it's quite so much
it's in the cream now it's not the jim
jones kind of you know
perception right so are you still the
only
medically supervised clinic that's doing
this well you know i'm really excited
because i just visited yesterday
one of our doctors that trained with us
nathan gerschfeldt is running a facility
here in the los angeles area and he's
it's beautiful i went to see his
uh facility and it's absolutely
beautiful and for anybody that uh
you know and also we have another doctor
uh
dr ewan in ohio that's opened up a small
facility
is doing really well i've gotten
excellent feedback from people we have
other doctors that we train we have an
intern residential training program
and those schools i mentioned texas a m
there's other medical schools
the naturopathic professions uh
graduates can come and spend a year as
an as a resident
doing a rotation at the triumph health
center the chiropractors often come and
spend three months
as part of their training at the truman
health center and those doctors were
hoping to open up more facilities around
the country
and we make uh people that contact our
website can get
access to whoever the local right
fasting supervisors are we're happy to
provide that
uh information and it's really exciting
to see these guys
not only learning how to do it but
actually figuring out how to get these
places open and offer affordable care to
people
and you know the thing uh that it's
always gratifying to see the clinical
results that they're seeing because it's
really a hard
thing to do in an outpatient practice
yeah unless you can control a person's
environment
it's hard to really induce these kinds
of profound changes
it's got to be incredibly gratifying as
a medical practitioner to see
such dramatic results well i think
that's one of the reasons we've been
successful we have a dozen clinicians
now with the truman thousand we have
five medical doctors we've got
osteopathy chiropractic naturopathy
all represented and these doctors once
they come they often are with us
their entire career in fact dr clapper
just retired
after nine years at triathlon we joke
that we're like the firm
you know once they start yeah and but
it's because they like the low
patient intensity in others they're not
having to see high volumes of patients
so they're spending a lot of time with a
few people instead of a little time with
a lot
they like the the center set up where
the doctor's able actually to get all
that intense education done
without it coming out of the visit time
that they can spend the visit time
really working with a patient's specific
needs
and they like the idea that people get
well
and so the combination of that allows us
to keep the doctors even though they
probably work harder for less with us
than they would if they went off and
worked for the local hmo or whatever it
is that it's enough gratification and
enough benefit
that those doctors really like working
at treatment health
and what that what is the kind of
current
relationship that you have with the
conventional you know medical
establishment like how are they
perceiving what you're doing well it's
been a revolution actually it's been
amazing change because when dr sultana
who's been with us now about 20 years
came the first thing we did is we got
him to take a job
with the local hospital as an urgent
care doctor
and so he became known to the medical
staff there and the nurses and he's such
a wonderful doctor they loved him
and so that allowed us to have a good
relationship with the immediate we have
a
trauma center you know just a mile away
and so
some of their nurses or patients of ours
we provide
chiropractic support to the nurses at
that hospital the uh some of the
hospitalists
purchased their food through our
outpatient deli so we have a good
working relationship
and now that they're seeing some of our
referral
uh patients that we're doing for
diagnostic workups and people getting
well
that's really helped too because they're
not used to seeing people actually
recover
and so today it's completely different
than it was
20 years ago where we were seen as some
kind of you know
crazy people now i think they see it as
a little bit
odd and different but at least for
people that have whatever it is they see
get well
acceptable right right and they know
we're well intentioned the other thing
that's made a big difference is we've
published a number of papers in
peer-reviewed medical literature
including on the safety of fasting the
effect of fasting on high blood pressure
we've recently finished a study with the
mayo clinic looking at primary
prevention of stroke
that's in review right now in a major
journal we're hoping that we'll get
positive uh publication of that here in
the next couple weeks
we've done a study with luigi fontana
from washington university looking at
biomarker changes in the gut microbiome
before and after fasting right we have a
couple other studies that we're
enrolling in right now so now we're
getting some affiliations with some of
these major players like
um walter longo which is going to allow
us to get into journals that we might
not otherwise have been able to access
because of the power that these guys
bring yeah his credibility and his
pedigree i would imagine is very helpful
oh he's done unbelievable just fabulous
work and he's a wonderful guy
yeah you know we're so fortunate that
you know we've got these kind of people
out there
trailblazing into the scientific and
medical literature
because as clinicians and particularly
alternative health clinicians we're not
always viewed
uh with the most open uh mindedness from
much of the medical profession yeah
well the other big piece here is the
diet and nutrition piece
i would suspect that a lot of people
come to true north because they saw
you and they saw those case studies
portrayed in
in what the health the documentary we
all saw
those individuals they're kind of before
and after stories that were very
dramatic
um and hardly criticized
and heavily yeah controversial for sure
we have uh people telling us i see
there's stuff on the internet that says
those people were all paid actors
you know reverse photoshop and i've seen
some unbelievable
kip and keegan just kind of grabbed them
randomly right like how did that happen
they they showed up and wanted to do the
film so we did some interviews then they
came back and they said well they've
decided they wanted a little more
can we just interview some of your
patients and they went out to the
courtyard whoever happened to be
standing around yeah i wish we could
have cherry-picked it and stuff because
there was that one guy he had all his
pills you know he went through all of
his medications and all that kind of
stuff
is that type of experience is pretty
routine yeah true north we see
what looks like miracles it's not
miracles at all it's just getting rid of
the crappy diet instituting a whole
plant food sos free diet and using
fasting effectively
you know that's the reality um and i
know they've got a new movie coming out
and i know they've done
a bit of filming with us as well also
i'm very excited that i think it's
september netflix decided to do a
special on wellness
oh they did and one of their six shows
was filmed at the true north health
center oh wow
and it's on fasting who's behind that do
you know
um i can't i don't recall that yeah who
the
producer and what else but it's i know
it's purchased by netflix
it's a netflix original oh that's cool
you know so i know it's gonna get pushed
out
i had john lewis in here a couple weeks
ago
um who's working with with keegan on the
hungry for justice project and so i've
been behind the scenes kind of looking
at
what they're doing that's going to be a
really big one i imagine it'll be very
controversial and probably piss a lot of
people off i'm really excited to see it
keegan
that's that's keegan's specialty yeah
but all right so the food part um the
the protocol
that you're that you recommend and that
you
you apply with your patients is you know
owes its
debt of legacy to caldwell esselstyn
and you know a whole legion of those
pioneering doctors who have put
the whole food plant-based diet onto the
forefront of public awareness we've seen
it
grow in adoption and recognition
and we're seeing the benefits of that i
think it's still
you know um somewhat controversial
there's all these diet wars with the
loaf the low carb people and now ketosis
and all of that so that's kind of all
kind of going on in the background here
but
maybe you know you can just speak to why
you believe so strongly
in a whole food plant-based diet well
the exclusively whole plant food diet i
think is
has a lot of support whether it's john
mcdougall or esselstyn
or you mentioned one of my heroes um t
colin campbell
you know just a brilliant guy so they
all make a very compelling case that
people should eat a whole
plant food diet and essentially you call
it a whole plant food diet i notice that
you always do that instead of calling it
a whole food plant-based
diet what's the reason for that so i
want a whole i want whole plant food
diet because a plant-based diet implies
that yeah
it's based on plants but it allows room
for it allows flexibility interesting
and so i think that dr mcdougall and dr
campbell would argue that we want to
have as broad a diet as possible to
attract as many people as possible
because remember most people in the
vegan vegetarian movement
are not just interested only in health
but actually dominantly in animal rights
moral ethical and spiritual reasons
environmental impact
and so their argument is well maybe it
doesn't have to be mr perfect you know
diet if it encompasses a broader range
of people we'll get more people doing it
we'll save the planet we'll save the
animals we'll go to heaven whatever it
is
and i don't disagree with any of that
that's that's great but when it comes to
maximizing health
if a person's overweight wants to lose
weight if a person has heart disease
diabetes if they've got cancer
or if they're healthy and their goal is
to live the maximum healthy life
possible i believe
the evidence supports the idea of an
exclusively whole plant food diet
that's free of sos sos is the
international symbol of danger
and it stands for salt oil and sugar now
can you have a little salt and still be
healthy yes
just like sometimes people can have a
beer and not be a drunk
but for my patient population which is
either sick people that want to get well
or the healthy people that really want
to maximize their health
a whole plant food sos free diet i
believe will prove
to be the most health promoting diet out
there now is it the best diet for
society to add
no i'm not arguing that i'm so grateful
that people like dr campbell and dr
esselstyn and dr mcdougall are out there
educating the world i'm not that nice of
a person i'm only interested in my
patient
and the and the maximizing the people
that that's in front of me and the
people that i see are often sick or
healthy and want to stay that way
and so i believe that is the best advice
for them now does that mean somebody
can't have a more flexible diet and
still be healthy
of course they can and if it's working
for you that's great i'm not going to
argue with it
but if you're struggling don't pretend
that there's not another level of
compliance that's possible
and i suggest people try it this way
because they might find out you know
they don't miss all that salty sugary
stuff anyway and they
may be just as happy and if not that's
fine if you can modify the diet maintain
the numbers not screw up our outcome
data
you know i'm not a policeman i'm just
trying to give you the best advice i can
but i i do believe i'm right now if it
turns out i'm wrong
and the evidence supports that you're
better off having more than 1500
milligrams of sodium a day because
that's an important reason for some
reason
then i'll change my recommendation okay
i'm recommending what i'm recommending
based on the combination of 36 years of
clinical experience watching people get
well
and my ability to interpret the
scientific literature
and the and the staff that we have at
the true north health foundation that
are doing the same
and so up till now a lot of the stuff
that we used to advocate
was criticized heavily most of the stuff
that we've been advocating if you go
back for 36 years has been
accepted as reasonable the two things
that we do that are still controversial
is recommend a lower sodium intake than
some of our colleagues
by in this type of diet ends up having
about a gram of sodium in it
naturally and water only fasting and i
believe
in both cases the data is going to prove
we're right
what do you say to the the low-carb
proponent who
tells you uh listen you know we need
some of these oils in our diet you know
healthy
olive oil has its place we've seen that
in the mediterranean diet
we've had tremendous results with people
losing weight and
maintaining their weight and reversing a
whole litany of conditions so
you know why not just go that route like
what when you have to
measure those two protocols against each
other how do you
well there's a number of protocols
you're actually covering there yeah like
for example these things get conflated
in this conversation
the uh the dead dr atkins diet the high
protein high fat diets they'll argue
what we got weight loss i don't disagree
and a lot of times what's really good
for short-term benefit isn't necessarily
the same thing that's good for long-term
outcome
same thing in athletics you can inject
antibiotic steroids and you can get some
pretty powerful short-term effects but
then you get the testicular atrophy and
you get cancer and die and it's not so
good in the long run
so what's good for short-term weight
loss isn't necessarily the same thing as
what's good for long-term health support
and i don't disagree that a lot of these
programs are effective for weight loss
heck
you can cut the hip off at the leg and
lose 40 pounds overnight
now it may not be you know a net benefit
to you
but just because you want instant weight
loss there's lots of things you can do
as far as the other alternatives which
is maybe a higher fat low protein
diet in inducing a ketogenic state that
may very well have some short-term
benefits it may even have some
long-term benefits but when you compare
the results that we see clinically
in the conditions that we treat there's
nothing i've seen that's worked better
than exclusively whole plant food sos
free diet
and i have the luxury of having patients
living with me sometimes for a period of
a year or more
so we're able to really test the diet
and see
what it takes for them to actually
recover their health that's one of the
downsides of living with your patients
because if they don't get well
who can you blame right they've been
with you we've got wow you have people
stay
with you for a whole year sometimes
longer than a year i've got people there
now
longer well sometimes we've had people
checked in that we're being sent to the
nursing home
we came as the alternative and then they
get well and go home and it was you know
two thousand a month less staying with
us then at the nursing home so
you know for those individuals it was an
economic benefit
other people come in because they're
gonna do long-term fasting long-term
recovery
they've got serious health problems
sometimes it takes a couple months just
to get people off all their drugs
some people come in because they don't
feel comfortable living freely
because they've got some issues with
food and eating they want to live in a
controlled setting until they really get
it down
so they feel comfortable going out there
and same thing true with alcoholics some
people you say quit drinking and they
quit
some people go to outpatient treatment
they do great some people do 30 day
programs
some people do 90 day programs some
people you know
have to do longer yeah so you have to
make it to
meet the patient's need so i'll tell you
a funny thing
we have this phone coaching thing i told
you about and so one of our doctors uh
dr chili veras does a lot of phone
coaching with people
and so people would call upon me and we
decide okay they need to come in and
fast but it's a couple months before we
have an opening so i say why don't you
work with dr varess in the meantime
and when you come in you won't have to
be here so long you'll and then they go
and get well
and it's happening a lot i'm giving her
a hard time you got him well before he
could come here we couldn't even screw
up our study or our documentation
they're all well you know
but it's okay how many how many beds do
you have though you probably are at
capacity most of the time yeah we have
yeah we can handle about 70
people so we're right we're going to run
about two months or so out
you know it was interesting after the
covet thing
all of our foreign people had to cancel
and that's 15 of our people we had 50
people who couldn't get in
but we had so many more local people
because now people can work from home
so some people that wanted to come in
but they you know they couldn't
afford to miss work during the very time
so they're working so
some people are able to come in and do a
fast but then they can during recovery
they can go back to working remotely
because we have excellent wi-fi
bandwidth and all that stuff
so you know those patients are able to
actually function
you know in a controlled setting but not
necessarily miss work
um sometimes we have situations where
they've got kids
well now we have like suites that people
book family units so they may come into
fast but they can have their family
there
and so the family learns to eat good
food and there's no cooking you know
and so there's lots of different ways to
adapt to people's needs depending on
what it is they're really wanting to
accomplish
our limiting factor is we have to have
highly motivated people that really want
to pay the price to get well
yeah and if that's the determining
factor in success i mean it's so similar
to the recovery community i mean you
have
outpatient you know situations you have
input i mean i did inpatient for 100
days and
you know now i think i should have
stayed longer like it was it was
it had such a dramatic i mean it saved
my life and it
gave me a new life but i needed that
much time and then
you know a lot of people from that
experience and i work with people today
who
are in halfway houses or you know sober
living facilities there are all these
transitionary
scenarios that are available to people
to help them
not just create these new habits and and
and you know build a new foundation for
their life but you need that support
system in place in order for it to
really
lock in so that they can carry it out in
the world
in a permanent way you know we have a
because we're a 501c3 nonprofit research
driven organization our price pro
is quite modest our rights are the same
as they were 12 years ago 149
chef aj goes she's like it's cheaper for
me
to go to hotel we actually have
businessmen sometimes they'll choose to
stay with us when they're on the road
because they get their meals and
it's cheaper than the doubletree you
know what i mean so you need to charge
more
well no the idea is or you need more
beds or i don't know we want to keep the
price point as low as possible
there's a reason we haven't raised rates
in the last 12 years is because
people need to stay long enough to get
well they need to be able to come back
if they need support
and by keeping as low rate as possible
it broadens the
number of people that can actually
afford to insurance cover it the
insurance will cover their medical exam
the all the traditional
medical management things not the part
where you get well that of course
wouldn't be part of health insurance the
daily rate at the center the 149
but if to seeing the medical doctor
getting any scan or lab that would be
treated just like it would any
insurance what is interesting though
people that have medical savings
accounts
that covers the state at the center
fully because you are
temporarily disabled you are under
direct medical supervision you are being
treated in an inpatient
basis it seems like with the explosion
in the rates of obesity and diabetes and
all of these
you know chronic lifestyle ailments that
are
debilitating millions of people every
year and escalating at a shocking rate
that there would be clinics like this in
every city available to people because
it really is
an opportunity for you to reboot and
reframe your relationship
to the habits and the foods that you're
eating that are
creating these problems in the first
place otherwise you just become
a ward of the pharmaceutical industry
well i hope you're correct i hope you're
predicting just exactly what we're
starting to see new facilities opening
but you also have to remember
any place that makes you give up coffee
alcohol
tobacco meat fish foul
eggs dairy products oil salt sugar yeah
and maybe consider fasting
i mean that's a tough yeah yeah you know
i have patients that their friends say
well what do you go there too fast just
come you can come to my garage i'll give
you the hose you don't
want to charge anything yeah that is
true
although you know i think when people
are looking at that quadruple bypass
you know other those options don't seem
so
onerous anymore and i think the thing is
we've we've arrived at this cultural
moment where
anything uncomfortable is seen as you
know
optional in our lives right we're so
disconnected from
challenge and stepping outside of our
comfort zones and to tell somebody look
you've gotta
you know overhaul everything that you're
doing is
a difficult message it's it's a very
undigestable message
but at the same time like i know in my
own experience and look you've done this
with 20
000 people to get those people through
those uncomfortable weeks and have them
arrive on the other side where you know
you can pull the curtains open and the
sun shines in
and suddenly those foods they thought
were unpalatable actually taste good
their cravings have changed they
actually look forward to
their meals with these you know plant
foods i mean that's a
miraculous thing that i just wish more
people could discover in their lives
yeah it's it is a miraculous thing yeah
and i think
for the specific highly motivated
self-selected people that we treat
uh we have a really high satisfaction
ratio and we're still here which is kind
of a miracle in itself just the idea of
it
and you do have a really high rate of
people that maintain these these
practices you know we're interested how
closely do you
tabs do you keep on people we're doing
uh a uh adherent study
starting in january of next year which
is designed to do long-term tracking of
very carefully in terms of patient
actual dietary compliance it's actually
difficult research to do
in terms of monitoring specifically what
people are consuming and not consuming
but we've actually designed a study
that's going to let us do some really
long-term tracking of people because
what we're trying to find out is how
strict you have to be to get the best
ratio of return do you have to be as
strict as we say or could you be more
flexible like many of our colleagues
recommend programs
right problem we have with them is their
recidivism rates their
theory is that by being more flexible
with the diet you'll get more people in
our theory is by being strict with the
diet you can keep more people
in i can't prove that yet because that
data hasn't been done we did just
recently though do a retrospective
analysis
of 1100 people that had been to the
center and that had experienced
10 or more of weight loss looking at
what people had sustained that magnitude
of weight loss over a period of a year
and it was over 30 percent
and so although that means a lot of
people didn't maintain the full
magnitude of weight loss that doesn't
mean that they haven't improved their
overall health but just the fact that
people can do that and sustain that
and as much as a third of those people
apparently are able to that's to me very
encouraging
because under conventional treatment
weight loss is around 93 to 97
failure rate no matter what wow gastric
bypass when you look at who sustains
long-term weight loss what kind of
health benefits very poor
it's so poor that most physicians say
yeah it's not even worthwhile just let
them be fat
forget about it right um what is the
study
that you'd like to see done whether with
respect to fasting or
or eating a whole plant food diet like
what what
where's the gap right now well the real
gap is
looking at what effect on healthy people
does healthy living have and
what effect on healthy people does
periodic fasting have in terms of
preventing them from ultimately getting
debility
and that's why we're doing what we call
this navigator study where we're going
to enroll a large number of people
and track them the rest of their life
and so the goal is to be able to
demonstrate now it'll take us a while
you know until they reach that that
point uh and it's particularly a problem
because once people adopt this diet and
lifestyle habits they tend to live a lot
longer my mother when she turned 92
years old
she used to get all kinds of trouble
from her friends because her son's crazy
diet that she's fine but at 92 she
realized she had outlived all
52 of her lifelong friends they were all
dead
and she said she realized here she was
92 years old
everybody was gone and she said alan you
need to warn your patients
if they're going to eat this kind of
diet make younger friends
much younger because she said even the
people 10 years younger
didn't want to play bridge and do stuff
they were too busy suffering with their
consequences
so the bottom line is that it's likely
that if you avoid the causes of
premature death
you know you're still going to die
you're going to reach your genetic
potential someday
but the period of debility may be
dramatically reduced
so you have to be prepared to live a
fully functional life up until you reach
your genetic potential
and not count on vegetating in some
nursing home waiting for people to
change your diaper for the last 10 years
of your life
i like that you got your mom on board
well my mom and my father my father
actually when he when i just started
practice was having transient
shaming attacks had had to retire from
teaching because of cognitive decline
and he was really suffering he came in
and was probably one of my most diligent
patients
did the fasting recovered his health and
20 years later he helped edit the
pleasure trap
oh wow so you know he was cool he was
really good to see how both my
my mother and father uh you know got it
started later in life because
i didn't know you know yeah early enough
but uh and both ended up doing uh uh
doing really well
so that was good and good lives and good
deaths
deaths in close proximity to the end of
their life where
that's what it's about i think it's an
important issue it's oftentimes not
really addressed
that how valuable is this is to spend
the last eight years of your life
however long that's going to be
fully functional capable of taking care
of yourself and what percentage of
health care do we expend
on treating people where we don't affect
their all-cause mortality and we may not
even be improving the quality of their
life
but we're basically just fostering the
consequences of poor dietary choices
and oftentimes because people don't even
realize
that what they're doing is killing
themselves with their fork and knife
yeah and warehousing them through those
later years where
they're so uh debilitated that the
quality of life is de minimis at that
point
so we talk a lot about longevity how how
how many years are you going to live but
it's really about the quality of those
years
yeah healthy life expectancy to me is
even more important than life expectancy
an interesting life expectancy for the
first time is actually starting to drop
healthy life expectancy the number of
years you spend fully functional
that should be i believe the target and
that's what i believe that
where fasting can have the greatest good
is in healthy people that use it
preventatively
to stay healthy in conjunction with a
diet sleep and exercise regime that's
health promoting
are there other cultures overseas where
fasting is more a part of
the kind of mainstream well if you look
in germany
modified fasting at least the book
entire clinic and others are
covered by the system and i think
there's a little bit more acceptance of
it water only fasting is still pretty
extreme yeah and i think it's up to us
to actually demonstrate that what we're
doing is not only safe which we've done
but it's effective and and i can't say
that that's been done there's not enough
research done
but that's why the true north health
foundation is excited we have a
laboratory now
we have an affiliated irb so human
subjects communities can be
approved by people that actually know
stuff about um fasting in fact dr
clapper is one of the uh professional
members of the
irb and um we have a research team dr
meyers our director of research
and others that we've now hired to be
able to actually conduct these trials
we've got these affiliations with
researchers around the world some of
these
big impact researchers like walter longo
so hopefully we'll be able to do some
meaningful research in the next couple
years
we have a great human subjects
laboratory at the 200th health center
we admit a thousand people a year for
fasting already we
already have all the mechanisms in place
to conduct the trial to collect the data
you know it's happening and so for me
it's 36 years waiting to get to this
point to where we can actually start
doing meaningful prospective studies
we're there now and we're ready to do it
and the proceeds from the true north
health center
fund the true north health foundation
and so we're not dependent on exogenous
grants in order to we thank goodness in
order to be able to fund our research
because we can do it internally
and and that's perhaps one of our
greatest successes is really pulling
that off that's why you don't see i
don't think a lot of clinical research
being done by other than
university-based facilities with all
their politics we're really a
freestanding independent
research facility that isn't dependent
or beholden to anybody
and you need to educate the next
generation of medical practitioners
which is exactly what dr clapper
treasure to humanity is doing in this
like third act of his career going
around and lecturing to young medical
students
absolutely that's cool and that's what
our internship in residency training is
all about yeah
so you only have 70 some odd beds right
not everybody can go to true north so
what is the recommendation like how do
you talk to the person who's listening
to this or watching this who's looking
to make some lifestyle changes but isn't
ready to
you know just get in their car and drive
up to northern california we'll share
with you for foreign coaching service is
really great they can go into our
website and get access to a doctor
right where they sit for under a hundred
dollars they can do a phone consultation
where all of their
records have been reviewed and worked
with a doctor in detail on an ongoing
basis
they can talk to me for free they can
call and i'll help at least point them
in the right direction
send them to a place that's closest to
them hook them up with the appropriate
doctor whatever it is they need to do
or they can read the books now get dr
campbell's
whole book and read it or china's study
look at dr
mcdougall's excellent books star
solutions the start solution is fabulous
um dr esselstyn's book wonderful i mean
we've got so many great resources now
from people that are out there doing a
really good job representing the
scientific literature accurately
in it but in a way that people can
understand and they're meaningful and
useful
our website everything we do is freely
available on our website
at truenorthhealth.com so they can go on
there there's video
in fact we're just about to launch our
own roku channel where all of our
content is going to be available
including our
lecture program our live lecture program
at the center so people have
access to that kind of education and
support obviously
you know nobody should do a water only
fast
without medical supervision but if
somebody
does want to start experimenting with
some intermittent fasting or some things
that they could do at home like how do
you
what's the kind of advice that you give
to that the first advice it's really
important that history exam and lab they
looked at just because
the medications particularly can really
be complicated even with intermittent
fasting
unless you take care of the medication
complications
you know you can get yourself into a
little bit of trouble so whoever's
prescribing that medication
at least needs to be discussed with a
lot of times they don't know anything
about diet they don't even know how to
get people off drugs
and so that's why i would suggest find a
local uh plant-based doctor or use one
of our phone coaches to at least make
sure
am i a good candidate for this and then
they can tell you look you'd be a good
candidate you might want to do vulture
longo's programming you might want to do
here's something you can do on your own
these are things that are reasonable the
problem is people are so screwed up
from long-term dietary abuse and
medication complications
that even simple things like we'll just
eat a good diet yes that's great
anybody can do that but you still may
need to keep into account that you might
have to modify the the pharmaceutical
preparations that you've been given
inappropriately
and what about um people that are that
are
moving in the direction of eating a more
whole plant-based diet what are some of
the
sort of psychological tools that they
can rely on
that would be helpful in making them
successful in that switch well one thing
i'd say is keep it to yourself
don't become you know born again
hygienist where you're trying to shove
down your beliefs and other people's
it because it doesn't work very well
you're just going to antagonize
everybody around you and make a lot of
stress
so you can set a good example but my
advice is only answer questions that are
asked directly don't be going around and
and trying to shove your belief systems
and everybody else but support is also
important right having some
accountability to somebody
seems to be effective yeah and that's
why i always encourage people to
to take advantage of you know around the
country now there
are doctors that aren't complete idiots
that are trying to encourage and
advocate support the plant-based
uh physicians et cetera so there are
resources available that's one of the
reasons i'm excited about this phone
coaching business because we can expand
that
uh broad you know all across the world
this is you know
automated systems are highly efficient
we're adding more doctors to the list
as the demand increases so that there
will be people
and resources available to people that
are serious about making these diet
lifestyle changes honestly for
relatively healthy people
all they got to do is start eating a
whole plant food diet and stop the rest
of it
for those of the you that struggle
making those changes
those are then you have to find the
appropriate support that you need and if
you can have even one friend
that they don't even have to do it they
could just be tolerate you doing it that
does make a difference
yeah so right now you i'm sure know the
statistics better than i do
but something like 70 percent
of americans are obese or overweight
childhood obesity rates are through the
roof
type 2 diabetes epidemic is what
30 of america whatever it is it's going
to be more tomorrow
right these these things are escalating
astronomically
and this really is you know covid
pandemic aside like this is that this is
a you know a health pandemic epidemic of
a different nature
that um needs to be addressed in new and
different ways what we're doing right
now
certainly is not working and the path
forward and what you have so
beautifully demonstrated through a
lifetime of work is
to show that agency plays a huge part
here and that we can
take better control of our health by
making some pretty basic
simple lifestyle changes that are rooted
in evidence-based
medicine and science that are proven to
work i mean 20 000 patients
over the years the a level of success
that you've experienced
the long-term success of these patients
speaks for itself and it's powerful man
and so
for somebody who's listening or watching
who feels stuck who feels like they
can't make that change who
is mired in the vicious cycle
of the pleasure trap to be able to give
people a lifeline and say it doesn't
have to be this way that there is hope
and there is a way out i think is
you know that's god's work that you're
doing yeah we're having fun
you know and uh you know it's
interesting the uh the uh
feedback from the pleasure trap has been
interesting because that book came out
uh
more than that it's been a long time but
actually the sales of the pleasure trap
now are actually
increasing so it's take that message is
a message maybe you've been a little bit
of ahead of its time
but now it seems like it's resonating
with a broader audience
and that uh that's been really
interesting to see we have a new book
that we're working on right now on
fasting that will be on or be done by
the end of the year so we're excited
about that
actually dr lyle is finally coming
towards the end of his book that he's
been working on
for a number of years is he in hawaii
he's on
a white right now he's on a writing
sequestration in hawaii right now and
he's not to come home until he finishes
the book so
i had dr greger in here the other day
and i think there
he is now out there they're all out
there writing books together yeah so i'm
really excited i've heard
20 of the chapters off dr last book and
it's brilliant and it's i'm really
excited
to have him put that out there because i
think that's going to be a whole nother
you know message and another angle
that's going to be really necessary and
very useful
cool final question that i ask all of my
medical professional guests if you were
suddenly in the position of being the
surgeon general
in charge of making policy decisions and
regulatory decisions about health in
america where do you start well what i
would say right now the most important
thing is
recognizing that we need to make our
people less vulnerable
to the various diseases whether it's
chronic diseases like heart disease and
diabetes
or the acute diseases like cova 19 we
need to make them
less vulnerable so we have to start
educating people up that health results
from health
living so we need to fight to improve
the diet and lifestyle habits of people
because honestly you're not going to
completely avoid exposure to every
infectious
agent that comes along and we're not
going to be able to escape
heart disease cancer and diabetes unless
we adopt
healthful habits so we should be
incentivizing encouraging intimidating
whatever it takes people
to adopt a health-promoting diet
lifestyle my opinion is that
is close to a whole plant food sos free
diet with regular sleep and prioritized
regular exercise and prioritized sleep
as you can get that that's what's going
to result in healthy living
diet sleep exercise you do that you'll
do more than all the other
job boning that's taking place right now
powerful dr goldhamer thank you
my pleasure thank you for having me yeah
of course i appreciate it
thank you uh for sharing your powerful
testimony today
um if you want to learn more about dr
goldhamer and his works pick up the
pleasure trap book that he co-wrote with
doug lyle
and where is the best place to direct
people online to learn more about what
you're doing well if you go to
www.truenorthhealth.com
you'll get access to everything you need
if you want to learn specifically about
fasting
there's a website called fasting.org
which is a fast and compendium website
cool and i'll link all that up in the
show notes and
your phone's going to start ringing all
right
come back and talk to me again
[Music]
you